oh boy Jefferson hated banks he hated
banks he would have said see I told you
it's all those people up there we know
what their financial shenanigans who are
feathering their nest and while the
people know I mean he would be well the
Jefferson who sort of sitting up at
Monticello would be opposed to stuff
like this anything helping out the
bankers the the Jefferson the politician
the pragmatist would probably look at
this and say you know if we don't do
something it's you know it's it's bad
that we we've come to this point but
something has to happen or else is going
to be worse but this was his fear he
never he never really trusted the sort
of stocks and I mean he was very much an
18th century mind on this question land
and of stuff that you can touch all
those kinds of things are those are real
commodities and you know hard
commodities things that are real not
these kinds of you know instruments and
things that people are making up it all
depends upon confidence you know and
that's really what this is it's all in
some ways smoke and mirrors his
confidence do we believe these things
are worth that so he would have been
appalled because this would he would
have seen this as you know the you know
the sort of apotheosis of everything
that he thought was going to happen once
you started in with you know with Wall
Street he would have thought of his wall
street but you know Hamiltonian kind of
policies about investment and dead and
and instruments that ordinary people
have no way of understanding and even
the people who are doing them don't
probably don't understand derivatives
all the kinds of things that are
involved in all this so this this was
his nightmare of a financial system
you